propagation des armes et toutes les
questions ici sont liées à la situation
internationale bien sûr elle aux
résolutions importantes aux forums
internationaux avec la participation de
la russie j'ai remercié collègues pour
ce dialogue je dois dire que ce qui est
très important c'est la coopération
culturelle entre nos deux pays dans ce
demain nous allons aussi travailler
ensemble nos exportations ont augmenté
de manière considérable et cela signifie
que une relation commerciale sont de
plus en plus forte et que cette
coopération est très important pour le
pays nous en avons parlé avec mes
collègues et je dis que cette année je
dois aller à en russie afin de renforcer
ses relations économiques
merci monsieur le ministre est
maintenant mais c'est la preuve
mesdames messieurs
tout d'abord je voudrais exprimer ma
gratitude pour nos amis italiens qui
nous accueillent ici sur cette terre
italienne jeu tout à fait d'accord avec
le fait que la quatrième réunion du
conseil de coopération
technico-militaire s'est déroulé de
façon idéale
nous avons reconnu
là nous même l'opportunité de reprendre
ce dialogue nous avons traité des
questions d'actualité politique et
internationale entre nos différents
ministères
à l'issue de ces négociations je peux
dire que nous avons le même point de vue
sur la nécessité du mécanisme existant
qui permet d'analyser en détail
l'ensemble des questions qui peuvent se
poser aujourd'hui nous avons noté un
certain nombre d'orientations majeures
qui doivent nous permettre d'agir de
façon concertée et notamment en matière
de sécurité
nous avons une situation qui n'est pas
tout à fait rassurante et et cette
politique de retenue des états unis et
des pays occidentaux vis-à-vis de la
russie
me semble dangereuse notamment avec la
l'extension des structures des
infrastructures militaires de l'otan en
direction des le frontières russes dont
encore une fois là il faut s'en tenir
aux accords qui avaient été conclus
astana en 2010 et nous rappelons notre
attachement de notre attachement aux
structures de coopération internationale
qui ont été mises en place
et nous avons examiné en détail les
questions de stratégie et de stabilité
stratégique là le retrait des états unis
de l'accord sur les armements fait que
comme me l'a dit plusieurs fois le
président poutine nous attachons notre
manifestons notre attachement à la
volonté d'un dialogue et comme l'a dit
le président poutine donc justement nous
n'allons pas déployer nos armes en tant
que les américains ne le fera mais s'ils
le font nous répondront de façon
réciproque et nous sommes prêts à
discuter avec les pays de l'otan et
d'autres pays sur les modalités de
déploiement des armements et simplement
il n'y a aucune réponse à nos
propositions si ce n'est l'exception du
président macron et monsieur le ji di
maio voix l'a dit aussi on pourrait il
n'y a pas de raison de refuser
l'invitation du président poutine a
participé à de telles discutons
discussions nous avons parlé également
de l'accord sur les armes offensives les
états unis ne résiste pas aux
propositions que nous avons est mise et
nous avons parlé également de
document d'un accord sur la fin des
essais nucléaires et les etats unis ne
veulent pas signer ce document qui est
particulièrement fondamentale tout cela
crée une atmosphère de tension qui est
plutôt le désagréable
alors que prochainement nous devrions
avoir une nouvelle conférence de
discussion sur la question de la
prolifération des armes nucléaires
nous sommes d'accord avec nos amis
italiens sur le fait qu'il faut trouver
une solution politique et de discussions
pour résoudre la crise en libye comme
cela était déjà stipulé lors de la
conférence de berlin en janvier dernier
il faut inciter les parties libyennes en
conflit à se mettre à la table des
négociations
nous sommes convenus de poursuivre le
dialogue sur la question de la libye et
dans dans un avenir relativement proche
dans les prochaines semaines ne
pourrions nous on retrouvait concernant
la syrie nous sommes tous bien d'accord
sur le fait qu'il faut s'en tenir au
fonctionnement du comité constitutionnel
qui avait été lancé à genève en octobre
dernier et qui avait été validé lors des
conférences de d'astana encore une fois
nous avons insisté sur la nécessité
d'éliminer les derniers foyers de
terrorisme dans les zones concernées et
de falaises faciliter le retour des
réfugiés dans leur pays
ceci inclut évidemment leur
rétablissement
reconstruction des infrastructures et à
ce moment là il faut que la communauté
internationale sans politisation
interviennent sur le terrain pour aider
les réfugiés à se réinstaller
nous sommes bien d'accord sur la
question de l'importance des
négociations des discussions pour autour
du conflit israélo palestinien
la situation en ukraine nous l'avons
examiné encore une fois d'après
l'optique de du plein respect du respect
total des accords de minsk qui ont été
signés et nous avons expliqué certains
points détaillés à nos amis italiens
nous avons expliqué ce qui se passe et
notamment le frein posée par kiev à
l'exécution des oeufs
des accords de musique encore une fois
nous avons insisté sur la nécessité de
travailler en matière de lutte contre le
terrorisme et pour le relever les défis
de sécuritaire qui s'opposent
aujourd'hui nous avons traité en détail
des questions des relations entre la
russie et l'union européenne et nous
allons l'attitude de politique positive
et en faveur de normalisation de la part
de nos amis italiens et encore une fois
nous sommes pour nos impressions que
l'italie cherche à apporter une solution
et illustre ici ça sa démarche tout à
fait positive
nous avons également parlé des
célébrations du 75e anniversaire de la
victoire sur le nazisme la fin de la
deuxième guerre mondiale et du 75e
anniversaire de la création de l'onu
nous avons parlé avec monsieur le
ministre des différents aspects de nos
relations bilatérales et des accords
conclus au plus haut niveau
en examinant en détail les mécanismes et
l'emploi du temps qui peut être mis pour
que notre travail de coopération
puisse retrouver un rythme tout à fait
régulier et en mars prochain il y aura
la commission interparlementaire russes
ou italiennes qui sauvera on retrouvera
nous avons invité nos amis italiens à
l'exposition qui sera organisé en août
prochain à yekaterinburg et donc il y
aura une délégation italienne qui sera
aussi au forum économique de
saint-pétersbourg au mois de juin et il
y aura le conseil russo italien de
coopération économique et commerciale et
qui se tiendra dans le au cours du
deuxième semestre
bref pour conclure ce sont des
discussions tout à fait intéressante que
nous avons eu et je tiens à remercier
nos amis italiens pour leur accueil
chaleureux merci maintenant la parole à
monsieur girling bonjour je salue mes
collègues mais se dit maillot messieurs
lavrov et messieurs je goûte avec qui
nous avons aujourd'hui après une pause
de six ans avons tenu notre réunion
une réunion entre les ministres de la
défense
nous avons pu discuter des questions
d'importance tels que les relations
entre nos ministères à la sécurité et
cetera c'est un dialogue constructif
autour de plusieurs sujets clés j'ai dit
à mon collègue que le projet européen
est le temps ce sont les bases de notre
architecture de la sécurité à nous sont
également convaincus qu'il est
nécessaire de développer un dialogue
efficace
claire et concrète avec la participation
des acteurs clés sur l'arène
internationale pour qui et pour que les
intérêts stratégiques de nos pistes
soient respectés moscou étant des
participants clés à ce dialogue et pour
notre pays
il est impossible de ne pas tenir compte
de l'opinion de moscou dans ce domaine
et dans le cadre de l'otan l'italie
soutient toujours ce rôle de la russie
et notamment le conseil otan russie
étant souvent très important afin de
poursuivre les échanges sur la sécurité
internationale dans les relations
bilatérales
nous avons parlé de la présence des
militaires italiens et russes en afrique
moyen orient et dans d'autres régions et
cela montre que la distance entre nous
nous permet quand même d'avoir la
coordination et trouver les points
commandes dans des situations difficiles
en plus il ya d'autres secteurs comme la
science où il ya aussi des échanges
d'informations d'expériences par exemple
sur l'arctique où nous avons récemment
organisées les recherches sur la
géographie et nous avons de grandes
possibilités de coopération avec la
russie parmi d'autres formes de
coopération nous sont pour les échanges
d'expériences dans la lutte contre la
piraterie
nous sommes préoccupés par la situation
en syrie à l'italie confirme à son
engagement actif afin de fournir de
l'aide humanitaire et notre dialogue
d'aujourd'hui à créer des bases pour
tenir régulièrement ce genre de
rencontre merci messieurs goût mesdames
messieurs
tout d'abord moi aussi je tiens à
remercier nos hôtes pour leur accueil
aujourd'hui l'organisation de discussion
tout à fait constructive et je considère
que la réunion plus la rue aujourd'hui
constitue un événement important pour la
russie et pour l'italie dans la mesure
où un certain nombre de problèmes liés à
la sécurité internationales ont été
posées ces derniers années qui peuvent
être résolus uniquement en agissant de
concert et en discutant et dans ce
processus
les ministères de la défense de nos pays
et monsieur guérini pour l'italie et moi
même ainsi que les ministres des
affaires étrangères ont pu traiter des
questions d'actualité de contrôle des
armements des armes de destruction
massive et nous avons eu une discussion
détaillée sur toutes ces questions de
sécurité on voit effectivement cette
atmosphère de tension autour de la
russie mais il ya d'autres menaces
telles que le terrorisme l'immigration
illégale
et justement c'est bien que nous ayons
plus pu conjuguer nos efforts notamment
sur les questions de sécurité en afrique
notamment au sahel et nous sommes bien
conscients du fait que nous devons
travailler ensemble dans la lutte contre
le terrorisme et sans interférer dans
les rôles dans les affaires intérieures
ne pouvons néanmoins exercer une
influence
nous sommes bien conscients qu'il est
nécessaire de poursuivre nos échanges
réguliers et détaillée et pour éviter le
caractère imprévisible de certaines
actions et l'incompréhension encore une
fois tout cela dépendra de la bonne
volonté des parties à vouloir discuter
nous avons aujourd'hui une expérience
positive et nous avons proposé un
certain nombre d'orientations sur
lesquels nous pouvons travailler à
relativement court et moyen terme et je
tiens à remercier encore une fois
monsieur le ministre italien de la
défense de cette discussion constructive
merci maintenant la question
[Musique]
merci bonjour j'ai une question à
monsieur di maio assure la libye vous
avez a dit hier on vous avait parlé hier
de ce sujet et je voudrais savoir si
l'opération sofia sur la poussie
poursuivi quel l'accord existe dans le
cadre de l'union européenne le problème
de la libye c'est un grand problème et
il y as désarmement qui sont fournis là
bas même après la conférence à berne en
nous savons qu'il y a eu un embargo à de
la part de l'onu
mais c'est un bagout n'est pas respectée
et nous voyons que maintenant ils épient
continue de d'agir à l'aide de ces
armements mais sinon un voulons avoir un
cessez-le-feu à long terme et nous avons
besoin de l'aide de la fédération de
russie pour y parvenir si nous voulons y
parvenir nous devons comprendre que ces
gardes presque fini et nous devons faire
en sorte que les armes ne soient fournis
en libye pour mettre fin à ses
livraisons à l'union européenne l'onu
ont déjà appris les mesures y compris le
mandat
sur l'embargo et nous avons créé une
nouvelle mission il y aura une mission
aériennes maritimes et terrestres
c'est à dire que nous allons surveiller
la situation
nous allons utiliser la patrouille
maritime et si la libye le permet nous
allons aussi mené les patrouilles à la
frontière la prime
qu'est-ce-qui et de particuliers dans
cette mission tout d'abord je dois dire
que c'est une mission c'est pas facile
d'avoir le consentement devant cette pie
pour introduire cet embargo
et cela permettra de mettre enfin ses
livraisons par voie maritime pour qu'il
n'ya pas d'accès à ce vaisseau ce navire
nous allons coopérer avec les garde
maritime de la libye qui se base à l'est
de la côte
et en plus c'est la première mission qui
a été soutenue au niveau international
parce que cette mission et a perçu comme
la frontière qui permettra de mettre fin
à ses livraisons d'armes et nous
espérons que cette mission sera lancée
le plus vite possible et ce seront bien
sûr les
moyens militaires les avions les navires
mais la proche ce ne sera pas une
approche militaire ce sera une approche
qui vise à établir la paix à l'aide de
ses moyens si nous allons sinon mettant
fin à ses livraisons
nous allons permirent à un dialogue
entre les parties au conflit et les
parties pendant les discussions ont
montré qu'ils voulaient avoir ce
dialogue dans le format c'est un plus
qui permettra d'avoir des contacts entre
les parties et nous avons décidé que
cette initiative initiative italienne
c'est une bonne initiative a été
soutenue par l'union européenne ça peut
être un moyen effectif
ce n'est que la première mesure mais la
nécessaire car tu es votre question j'ai
une question à monsieur lavrov
l'union européenne hier à monsieur di
maio maintenant à confirmer qu'il aurait
une mission une mission en libye
mission terrestres aériennes et
maritimes et comment la russie peut
évoluer cette mesure ne serait elle pas
la répétition du scénario de l'ingérence
de l'otan en libye et maintenant avec ce
format a2 plus de est ce que vous allez
poursuivre par des consultations ont ce
qui concerne la décision prise hier par
les présidents de f1 par les mines et
affaires étrangères de l'union
européenne
monsieur di maio vient de répondre à une
question similaire
un représentant de la télévision
italienne notre position c'est que il
est nécessaire
s'en tenir strictement à la résolution
du conseil de sécurité de l'onu ne pas
entreprendre d'autres actions qui
relèvent des prérogatives de l'onu les
explications qui ont été données par nos
amis italiens sur les plans d'opération
navales aériennes et même terrestre pour
assurer le régime de protection de la
libye on nous a expliqué sa terreur et
nos amis nous ont promis de nous donner
une formulation plus précise de ce de
cette décision européenne
mais bien entendu si cette décision
répond aux exigences de la résolution de
l'onu
alors à ce moment là de toute façon la
décision devra être validé par le
conseil de sécurité de l'onu c'est clair
et c'est très précis et c'est ce qu'a
encore dit le président poutine à la
veille au moment de la préparation de
cette réunion bilatérale
donc il ya des mécanismes qui existent
mais qui peuvent être utilisés par tel
ou tel pays et nos collègues italiens
nous ont assuré qu'ils comprenaient
cette exigence mais au cours des
discussions de
on a rappelé le cas de l'année 2011 ou
le l'onu avait invité tous les payer a
participé à de l'otan pardon avait
décidé d'inviter d'autres pays à
participer à cette interdiction aérienne
sur le territoire de la libye
et cela allait à l'encontre de la
décision du conseil de sécurité de l'onu
donc encore une fois il faut respecter
ses décisions de l'onu
donc il était clair à partir du moment
où on mettait une zone d'exclusion
aérienne
ça veut dire que l'aviation de mouammar
kadhafi ne pouvait pas prendre l'air
c'est à dire que d'un autre d'un côté la
résolution du conseil de sécurité l'onu
était observée mais en même temps cette
situation permettait à certains pays de
mener d'opération militaire est ce que
je voudrais c'est que la décision de
l'italie et de ses partenaires de
l'union européenne
puis ceux correspondant aux exigences
légales
donc on sait très bien que les raisons
pour lesquelles certains pays veulent
mener l'ordre dans ces pays mais on voit
bien que l'union européenne ne veut pas
que d'art certaines armes se retrouvent
en libye mais je comprends bien que
certains pays de l'union européenne
pourront obtenir un certain droit sur ce
pays qui les arrange on est qu'ils
n'iront pas forcément dans le sens de la
résolution du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu est la deuxième question sur le
format de plus de exclure à des
consultations entre les deux
gouvernements au niveau des premiers
ministres nous avons un mécanisme
interétatique et qui dirigé par le
président russe et le premier ministre
italien avec la participation d'autres
ministres si je me trompe pas ça fait
six ou sept ans qu'il ne s'est pas
réunie mais il existe toujours il n'a
pas été fermé et comme je les ai
rappelés dans mon mot d'introduction
nous resterons actuellement l'ensemble
nous réactivons l'ensemble des
mécanismes de coopération qui existe et
vous avez justement là sous vos yeux une
nouvelle incarnation de cette reprise du
dialogue
et je pense que nous pourrons reprendre
toutes les activités des différentes
infrastructures qui avait été créée à
cet effet et qui avait apporté des
résultats positifs jusqu'à présent le
cameron et l'agencé
bonsoir mais se dit mayer les relations
entre la russie et l'italie ont leurs
traits caractère surtout en europe et
est ce qu'il y aura de nouveaux
partenariats entre nos pays et que sur
la leur influence sur l'union européenne
nous pouvons dire que depuis janvier
2010 9,1 du pilat visite du président
poutine
en italie nous avons ce format de plus
de l est a aussi d'autres forums pour
coordonner nos activités qui ont deux
tenues sur la libye notamment à les
forums entre les spécialistes techniques
et il y avait aussi des formes sur la
syrie et la turquie
il y à des échanges entre les diplomates
moi personnellement je vais à une
exposition exprom en russie et cette
physique
c'est cette visite sera organisée par
les agences économiques financiers des
deux pays
cela montre que nos relations sont très
intenses et cela dans un nouvel élan à
une relation de latéral pour que
l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale puisse profiter de ces
relations
la russie participe avec qui nous à de
nombreuses conférences ensemble avec
d'autres acteurs qui ce qui doit
permettre à résoudre y compris la crise
syrienne je remercie monsieur la preuve
de ce qu'il a dit à nous essayons de
résoudre la crise se basant sur le
mandat de l'onu la mission européenne
existe uniquement parce qu'il y a
en mandat onusien et ce mandat portait
sur l'embargo sur les livraisons des
armements et ce mandat ne porte pas sur
d'autres domaines
et maintenant la dernière question
ekaterina monsieur goût qu'elle volets
de la coopération militaire entre la
russie et l'italie sont les plus
prometteurs est-ce que vous avez parlé
avec votre collègue de la situation en
syrie
oui bien entendu au cours de toute cette
discussion nous n'avons pas cessé de
toute cette période nous n'avons pas
cessé notre coopération entre les
ministères de la défense malgré les
difficultés bien connu que qui sont
apparus ces derniers temps mais
l'orientation majeur c'est de notre
coopération c'est le le
le suivi des mouvements aériens et
maritimes pour éviter tout tout problème
nous espérons que très prochainement
nous pourrons ouvrir d'autres canaux de
discussion sur les rapprochements
éventuels entre différents
navires et avions mais aussi les
distances à respecter tout ça nous
préparons un accord portant sur des
travaux des opérations de sauvetage sur
des sous-marins en cas d'incident c'est
un accord important et j'espère que
prochainement nous serons en mesure de
le signer et de l'adopter
en pratique il y avait en plus des
travaux qui sont menés en matière de
lutte contre la piraterie et le
terrorisme international
nous sommes en contact permanent et nos
équipes spécialisées sont en contact
bien évidemment nous avons étudié
d'autres voies de coopération et un
grand forum sur la sécurité
internationale se tiendra à moscou
prochainement et nous avons invité nos
amis italiens y participer et
l'invitation qui avait été déjà émise il
ya plus de six ans pour participer aux
jeux olympiques du militaire
donc cette invitation avait été
renouvelé plusieurs fois mais pour
l'instant elle n'avait pas été honorée
aujourd'hui la police habilités existe
et j'espère que cet échange entre
militaires pour les sport proprement
militaires pourront se faire donc il ya
un travail de préparation à faire
évidemment mais j'espère beaucoup à voir
voir la participation de nos âmes et
donc il ya plus de 30 concours auquel
participent actuellement 37 pays qui
viennent de pays différents dans le
monde
donc j'espère que nos amis italiens y
participeront et il y aura aussi des
expositions notamment l'exposition armée
2020 qui est une exposition d'armement
qui se tient chez nous là tout ça c'est
ce qui concerne notre coopération
militaire
après en ce qui concerne la syrie
regardez ce qui s'est passé ces cinq
dernières années il y avait déjà une
coalition internationale qui existait
depuis deux ans qui était censée lutter
contre l' état islamique en syrie et en
irak et l'activité de la coalition il ya
cinq ans a débouché sur le fait que que
les autorités syriennes n'occupait que
17% de leur territoire alors
qu'aujourd'hui après la libération du
territoire fait par l'armée syrienne
avec l'appui russe fait que aujourd'hui
ce taux est de 90% est aujourd'hui le
point majeur en syrie c'est de restaurer
le pays de le reconstruire
et je tiens à vous rappeler que que
quand il y avait les destructions les
destructions à palmyre qu'il y avait les
exécutions de d'otages et aux portes de
pas le mien beaucoup de pays beaucoup de
spécialistes avaient cité des chiffres
pour la la reconstruction de palmyre ça
fait trois ans que palmer a été libéré
pendant ce temps la russie a assuré le
déminage presque totale du territoire de
palmyre et ce grand monument
d'architecturé d'histoire de
civilisation
doit encore être reconstruit j'espère
que l'argent qui avait été promis
viendra concernant les aspects
d'humanitaires au cours de l'année qui
vient de passer du lit vent du liban et
de jordanie
chaque jour on a à peu près 1200
personnes mais deux sont réfugiées qui
retourne dans le pays cela témoigne du
fait que les gens ont envie de revenir
dans leur pays
bien entendu il reste beaucoup de choses
à restaurer et un des aspects c'est au
moins la suppression des sanctions qui
ont été prononcées à l'encontre de la
syrie
ce sont notamment des sanctions sur les
éléments porteurs d'énergie et
aujourd'hui les gisements de pétrole en
syrie sont littéralement pillé sans gêne
par les américains alors que tout ça
appartient au peuple syrien
et puis en même temps il est interdit d'
ap
il est interdit d'apporter de faire
venir un du pétrole en syrie dont il ya
un vrai problème donc une grande partie
de la population qui souffre sur le
territoire syrien c'est le manque de
deux sources de chaleur c'est le manque
d'électricité puisque c'est interdit et
qu'eux-mêmes n'ont pas toujours la
possibilité de
ce assurer ses besoins essentiels
je rappelle aussi que beaucoup de
médicaments font l'objet d'interdictions
je vous rappelle aussi que des sanctions
est imposé sur l'équipement médical ont
été imposées donc là encore il ya un
travail à mener parce que si on parle de
la reconstruction du pays
on a bien vu que les bombardements les
tapis de bombes qui ont été déversés sur
le pays
on montrait que vous rappelle que les
états unis avaient dit nous accordons
des sommes d'argent pour la
reconstruction
or dans certaines de ces zones sont
toujours minées la mission d'évaluation
n'est toujours pas venu on attend
qu'elle vienne pour qu'elles effectuer
une évaluation
on sait qu'il ya plus de 50 personnes
qui meurent chaque mois sur des mines et
pas seulement ce sont des des femmes des
enfants des civils
voilà donc il ya un travail de déminage
qui doit être fait voilà aujourd'hui ce
qui se passe en syrie
c'est ça donc les forces en présence
assure un travail de reconstruction
autant que possible et dans les trois
derniers mois 2010 9600 entreprises ont
été recréés des écoles ont été rouvertes
des établissements médicaux il n'en va
pas de même avec l'équipement
agricole je vais pas retenir votre
attention trop longtemps mais vous avez
là ici quelques orientations majeures je
travaille que qui à faire en séries et
encore une fois tout ce travail doit
permettre la reconstruction de ce pays
qui a beaucoup souffert je vous remercie
merci à tous